here we go boys fresh off you're super
tired
daddy's uh daddy's shoulders were a
little uh rounded a little droopy yeah
but you did a lot yeah daddy's daddy has
worked every day since last monday this
is my
12th show in seven days yep yeah and two
of those shows was over four hours yeah
yesterday was five hours yeah but
yesterday's show that's easy work man
it's uh you know it's that hey kravitz
is he got a nice house a little house
little house little cup his house he
designed it and owns it oh he doesn't
live there though
got it he uses it for a bit like people
airbnb it i mean so you you've said that
this joke all the time like people that
don't think money buys happiness if
you've seen that video
oh it's [ __ ] insane huh where is it
it's in the hollywood hills
yeah you you go down laurel canyon right
we get off your left and go back up the
hill uh-huh i've never met that's
kirkwood
was he there
no i to be honest i was so busy man
because i i was like the the head coach
of the thing so i was the only one with
the earpiece so i had to
oh i had to be on it all right sorry
there's so many people coming in
he might have been yeah there's so many
like and there's so many celebrities
like walking in i i don't know what the
hell is going on yeah voted on think boy
chin
the house
uh marshall if the just the stream in
general
but yeah it was fun it was dope it's so
different than what we do you know yeah
it's just
it's not what you know it's not
it was the best athlete there is brandon
marshall
uh
yeah yeah yeah don't punch me in the
face who was that
brian marshall he was a
uh nfl great receiver he he was in his
prime when he played for the broncos
that's bubba wallace the nascar guy
that's kurt busch they have the daytona
of 500 i think today
i think so but they have it today
and then so you had them on you like
jerry who's fighting for the uh yuri
he's fighting for the light heavyweight
title yep you had tio fomo lopez on a
bunch of times
that's how you know you're old like the
tick tockers you don't even know they
are i was like uh what
they had this young indian kid on
handsome kid he just turned 21 and he
sits down and you know he's a number guy
from moneyline you know
cures
good funny guy good guy you know really
really handsome kid and he's like their
tick tock star that talks about
financials which is dope so what
moneyline does again i don't work with
moneyline it's just their things dope
what they do is they have a platform
right where they provide banking stuff
for you but they make original content
from like tick tockers and like big
instagram influencers and they make
original content so if you're
21 and you want to know should i rent or
buy this car you're going to get a kid
who's done that knows the game tells you
what why should rent or why should uh
why should lisa why should buy the car
buying your apartment that's really cool
yeah you get financial advice from
people who know better yeah that are
your age and you're getting education on
how to invest your money taxes why would
they have it
so it's peer-to-peer kind of stuff what
do you mean so in other words why would
they have it somebody
and he's your age he's like this is what
i did to get my first house these are
the steps you have to go through so
here's what you need to do so it's just
like yeah it's just dope like and i
didn't i just thought they were a bank
and you know we gave about a hundred
thousand dollars in super bowls okay
whatever but then i talked to the ceo of
he's like here's what we actually do man
like we're educating the young on like
investing in the crypto and all that
[ __ ] yeah nfts and we have this platform
where you go to if you don't know like
what where to invest or how to save
money or make money yeah we have all
these influencers that have done it and
tell you how to do it great so we've
never had anything like that that's what
he's saying he's like you're not getting
a new economy you're not going to get
this education yeah like college or high
school didn't teach you that that's the
whole economy think about that whoever
came up with that that's an economy
it's such a dope idea but that's the
back of the house so where all those
people are so that's like there's this
like almost like a living room back
there's the kitchen to left this huge
like tv room then there's the pool you
guys are inside where you see where the
lights are like underneath yeah yeah
yeah we're around originally when it's
outside i'm like that ain't happening
it's 90 degrees out you can't put the
town outside in the sun right so they
switched it look at mark you can see
mark right there
yeah you can right here yeah mark's my
guy man they had a dj there they had
nobu sushi catering like it was
literally i can eat that food but
whatever so i starved all day and then i
sat on the inside so then it went d
brand marshall tyson
and then dc just ate for four hours so
his team was there but they couldn't
hand the food because they'd [ __ ] up the
size you'll see me talk and just hand
burgers and chicken and [ __ ] tater
tots and all dog
the whole time and i go hey hey on the
air hey i look like poop spice that's
why you i look like postmates dc he goes
why you go i've been handing you food
for the last three will you stop eating
he's like i'm starving no i get you're
hungry you should be full though am i
right you should be full now because
you're full because i've had you seven
different he can items
what do you think he's at 240 oh heavier
than that 260. he's is he is he tall
he's so no hype mm-hmm
but he's not fat he's just thick he's
just the third guy like you bring up the
picture of his channel
yeah he's not fat like i even told him
like jesus christ dude you're in i
figured you'd let yourself go after you
he double legs
like luke rockwell made me quote unquote
spar move around with
him and yeah
and dc sitting there and
he was such a block and then he [ __ ]
grabbed me and double ate me and just
put his he kind of put his shoulder it
looks great into my my my chest and i i
was i tapped him i couldn't breathe just
by the pressure he's putting on he's
laughing and that was the only thing he
did to you he's so thick yeah it's well
i mean you know yeah dude he's daniel
cormier
[ __ ]
yeah he's he's not like out of shape
yeah yeah that's a classic would have
been dope to meet him
when people talk about that stain i
think that's makeup from uh cyborg
because he gave her a hug and she had a
bunch of makeup he is so thick so yeah i
didn't realize it was going to be like a
party i thought it was just like
literally you guys
going to be sitting there and just uh
commentating as the game no i did too
but no it was a straight part
of him right oh yeah for a long time
yeah
yeah for a long time
wrestling from him
not that i would never want to fight him
he beat the [ __ ] out of me yeah he lives
in dallas right
uh no he lives in san jose dallas
oh he's a great guy man
he's such a good guy yeah
um
um but it was great because cyborg doing
it she she i didn't really talk to her
again i was swamped that to be like the
the lead of it so it was like
a swamp man i i didn't i had so much i
said i said hide her i didn't get to
really
uh
talk to her much she's a dog mike was
great mike was smoking and he was like
dude you've never seen someone leave a
party faster than when we wrapped that
thing
i'm talking i it was like magic
he [ __ ] zoomed out of the took off
zoomed out um
he had a bet on the on the game he bet
on cincinnati so before we sat we sat
down and was like who are we going for
and all everybody's going for cincinnati
i was like well i'm going for the rounds
who the [ __ ] don't go for the rams and
then i said i got money on it man my god
it's gonna suck tyson because i'm going
for the rams man and then he was like i
got yeah he kept saying i got a lot of
money on it so my god i go well now i
got to cheer for since i only lose money
man yeah how much money you got you was
five grand ago
well i'm going for the rams now man you
can afford five grand dude i thought we
were talking like
five hundred thousand yeah yeah yeah i
said well done five grand or if i'll bet
you're five grand right now
out of that bit yeah go for the rams
dude
our boy cooper cups
[ __ ] up
dude how bad is uh um
uh [ __ ]
yeah it's gonna be bad but it looked
like he was just running he didn't get
hit no he didn't get hit no you could
you could just see the weight yeah the
way it happened he's having such a great
game
he got the first touchdown hey if you
want to get it if you're getting an
injury
unstoppable have you caught a touchdown
acl tornado is what they thought so they
it's confirmed that's bad here's what
else
says fear what about our boy joe burrow
and his knee uh he's okay he came back
after that yeah yeah but uh with odell
the i thought the game
watching like the opening like quarter
like that first quarter yeah it's about
to be a blowout like rams about to beat
the shadow because they scored really
fast obj then you got a double uh coupe
and then obj's i was like oh and i
called i was like obj's gonna be your
mvp he's gonna go off yeah they can't
they gotta pick their poison like being
like coop go off and let
obj we can't control both of them then
when obj got hurt notice it was a closer
game but if he never got hurt that
things would blow up because because
they can't stop them they can't stop
those guys we gotta pick one you're not
gonna shut down both and then even
though there's no obj [ __ ] cooper
cops still having people
winning
monster what a [ __ ] stunt dude and
what's what's dope is that that coach uh
sean mcvay who's 36 years old
yeah yeah so dope what he realizes that
uh he needed to get cooper
open and so he didn't want the defense
get rest he knows cooper can go all day
so that's why they they were doing a lot
of no huddle yeah trying to wear out the
defense stop the rush and get cooper
open oh you want to press them and
pressing because they know cooper can go
all day smart he can go all day that's
[ __ ] amazing yeah that game was sick
i bet you were having you were happy for
your boys yeah yeah i love it that's
good man bought the jersey ordered two
weeks ago and still
february 28th well let's take a little
break b with chapelle lacy you myself
because guess what man we got to take a
break because i know everybody's sad to
come down the super bowl is over maybe
you made some money maybe you didn't
lost yep bingo's lost and you're sad
football's over but don't be sad cause
draftkings can still make money man
download the app right now you got a ufc
this weekend you got freaking nba
popping off all right you gotta get it
done download the draftking sportsbook
app right now use the promo code fighter
all right use the promo code fighter
and the promo code is fighter at
draftking sports with the official
sportsman partner of the freaking last
super ball sunday and you know they're
the official sportsman partner the ufc
they got it all man but 21 or older
minimum age and location requirements
vary by jurisdiction see draftkings.com
sportsbook for a full list of
requirements and state-specific
responsible gaming resources voidware
prohibited gambling problem call 100
gambler in tennessee call or text
tennessee redline 1-800-889-9789
in connecticut call
888-789-777-7 or visit ccpg.org
chat write this down in new york please
write this down in new york because dude
can you not remember this
in new york call 8778 hope ny or text
hope ny 467 369 if you're still
listening and you want to bet on the ufc
this weekend or the nba or whatever you
want use draftkings download the
draftkings sportsbook app right now it's
the official sports partner the nfl and
ufc and use promo code fighter
i don't i look there's a way to
refinance your student loans and and it
takes two minutes first of all to see if
you're eligible it doesn't affect your
credit score i'm talking about earnest
here okay if you want to pay off your
student loans faster listen up okay
student debt a major problem this
company
for earnest can save you thousands with
refinancing federal st student loan
payments they're on hold but with rates
rates this low now is probably a good
time to refinance before they sh you
know jack rates back up if you could
save on your student loans what would
you do with extra cash man so many fun
things you could do
take a trip ernest has some of the
lowest rates flexible payments an
in-house team ready to help you out with
earnest you can change your interest
rate get a lower monthly payment you
never pay fees not even late fees all
right by refinancing you can reduce your
loan term save money combine multiple
loans and a simple monthly payment can't
even talk to a real human being at
earnest for help all right with earnest
it only takes two minutes to see what
your new rate could be there's no credit
impact right now ernest is offering the
firing listeners and viewers a hundred
dollar cash bonus refinance your student
debt at earnest.com fighter not
available in all states once again you
get a hundred dollar cash bonus when you
visit earnest.com fighter to refinance
your student loan
visit earnest.com for more details not
available in all states terms and
conditions supply are you writing this
down earn a student loan refinancing
made by earnest operations llc nmls did
i speak slowly enough okay write this
down that's very important number 120 49
17. this is really important california
financing law license number license
number you got this okay 605 oh thank
god everything was real okay yeah but i
got to do that dude i got to give you
that dude if i want to show up there
what's the address because i'm thinking
about driving out there just to talk if
you want to stay i need the address yeah
this is 535 mission street san francisco
i've been there in san fran that's close
do you want this to be live now
now let me let me give you the zip
94105. look just visit earnest.com
licenses for a full list of licenses oh
yeah because i i need to do that you
need the licenses dude god i still i
stole your i was doing this thing for
this the second screen experience and i
was doing uh i stole your whole thing
this is me i'm i'm so because i i didn't
know anything about you i didn't know
anything about [ __ ] cooper coming to
you you talked about it and i'm doing
this i'm going can he get some love
where's the budget contract for my boy
he's like how does this kid come out of
east washington nobody even talks about
it
oh dude stealing it like and now i'm
talking to pro football players and i'm
and i'm doing this i'm going look look
the thing about joe burrow i don't know
i just i found flooring about here about
a month ago when i heard he was cocky
the thing about joe burrow if you are a
defensive coordinator you want to make
the quarterback unhappy if he doesn't
like the pass you forcing the past
didn't like to run anything
yeah i'm doing that there's no they
can't do that with him he's got that x
factor around the pros football players
come truth facts right there there you
go there you go brian so full of [ __ ]
yeah the game was dope
you know what most football players are
not good at though explaining should
detail the way you do because a lot of
them like so ask me about what ask me
what the rams need to do it's third
quarter what should the rams do at the
end of the day man they gotta get the
ball down the field and you gotta
execute and if you don't execute then
then what happens is see if i'm on
defense i'm thinking how fast can i get
the ball to the offense you know okay
no [ __ ] i'll tell you what thank god
daniel cormay did that show with me man
because originally it was me tyson in
the game kevin garnett i'm like i don't
know them dude
not just that well there's no chemistry
and then also they they have no
background in any sport so they can't
they're just trying to so what i told
specialized they're so special yeah and
so what i told uh moneyline who's
booking say i go get a guy who can talk
man so i because it's a five hour
[ __ ] program yeah i can talk five
hours but yeah i don't know if these
guys are gonna be down to do that it's a
lot of energy and creativity i said you
got a guy who who has done that before i
said get dc he's a good friend of mine
very smart we have chemistry very smart
he can bounce ideas off him you can't
just have a bunch of athletes no and
then brandon marshall's a beast brandon
marshall has
he's graced yeah he's just drank a
little too much tequila and was
[Music]
a little yeah what do you mean flying
off the hinges he was like trying to
fight everybody tyson like in a playful
way oh yeah but then i you know once you
keep poking the bear like he's [ __ ]
with tyson you got to see the video
was tyson was tyson uh
he was like you better quit making fun
of his [ __ ] feet
see what happens
and that's tyson i'm probably not
[ __ ]
mushroom's end highest yeah
he said he goes through 50 blunts a day
50 he doesn't smoke almost smoke and
then whatever put it down but yeah he's
a professional blunt roller
brandon marshall's huge he's a wide
receiver he's [ __ ] huge yeah big boy
yeah he's tall
he's but yeah thank god he was there too
man because he can chat he's judged he
was he was on the broncos oh yeah and he
did he did was he part of that winning
team uh no he was at jake you met him
before you did we worked with him i've
worked with him that's why oh okay yeah
they told me i'm like thank god yeah
because and he knows football like a
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah smart guy yeah
yeah really smart guy really really
smart guy and chris his podcast is huge
is it yeah he crashes crashed good for
him what's this podcast called i forget
look it up that something my athlete
his huge guest on he said he wants to
fight trail owens i am an athlete
he wants to what he wants to fight trail
owens because he's like that'd be down
to fight because i'm about
how he could beat up dc and then and
then we got into it they said greatest
athlete of all time and i was like mom
it's me interesting we got a bunch of
athletes there let's see what we're
going and then uh brian rush goes uh
bruce lee he's nothing bruce lee and i
hey i went he's dead so everyone's
definitely dead seriously he goes i
think it's bruce lee does he know he's a
much better athlete i was like very cool
i took i started taking my stuff
that's my time i'm going to leave now
and i go you broke my heart man you
broke my heart brandon i probably and it
goes you know he's never competed and
then dc goes it's true man he can't be
the best athlete and he goes yeah but
some of the stuff he says i go well if
we're going based off that is jordan
peterson the best athlete you've ever
heard of what are you talking about yeah
just because he has good quotes
and he was inspirational but as far as
competition i want to take you to teach
brandon marshall something to beat the
[ __ ] out of bruce lee like about two
months a month less than that or maybe a
couple days so big a couple days
but then uh and then dc which also broke
my heart he said whoever won the
decathlon he goes so when uh caitlyn
jenner was uh bruce jenner yeah that was
the best athlete on earth and i said dc
well you're completely wrong because how
many people compete in the decathlon how
many go throughout the week it was
designed to find the best athletes so
it's got running sprinting along this
but that's okay then whoever wins the
[ __ ] toughness best athlete but it's
like in the decathlon how many people
actually compete in the decathlon lebron
james not doing it no no uh [ __ ]
jalen reigns ramsey's not doing von
miller's not doing it donald uh you know
but actually there's there's an
interesting argument to that because
arguably someone like vaughn miller or
anybody
because
the decathlon is about throwing
jumping
sprinting but also a marathon
right
and you know what would happen if those
guys focused on that the real athletes
went oh i got okay and they'd since they
were keep up all the events let's take a
look at these if they did it since they
were kids it's so stupid to say it's the
best athlete because our best athletes
aren't competing in that right they're
they're on they're making money now that
might be the toughest company making
money in the nba and it might be the
toughest company they're making money at
the highest level where the most people
participate yes well
players i'd throw in there in the mix i
mean in terms of like because the world
sports the guys that really it's a
really interesting question it's the
hardest sport to go pro in but i don't
know like messi who's much smaller would
never be able to play football but he's
so ridiculous or you know or or ronaldo
is is just a whole different level but
but it's apples and oranges those guys
are so cause you look at tom brady not
the most athletic but he has a certain
set of skills for the problem that's
really yeah best quarterback but then
they got upset because i said if you
want because they said uh serena
williams excuse me the the 150th man
would beat the [ __ ] out of her so i said
best female athlete i'll give you that
yeah you can't say best athlete because
we know for a fact that i think they did
play the 150th ranked man that's correct
beats the breaks off of her and you know
i said so that doesn't work and then you
know they're all no blah blah and i go
if we're going to go down that road if
we're going based off statistics as
someone who dominated their sport the
most it was the most the most outlier of
all time it's wayne gretzky no one will
ever touch his records forever and then
that they were like oh we're out bruce
lee's better all right
all right you don't want to the question
then becomes because wayne gretzky
didn't have any way his puck speeds
skate speed nothing was off the charts
at all in fact it was very average yeah
but he's very fast
he's very fast compared to other guys
yes no no
mcdavid broke his record for speed and
alex i will say
wayne gretzky is one of the best hockey
players of all time but
uh the game's different so it's hard to
compare them to players nowadays it's
not though no this this isn't the
argument the argument's not who would
adapt to the today's rules because if
you do that with the nfl and nba then
dennis rod and michael jordan are
playing a different game that doesn't
matter yeah i'm talking about goal
scored point score i would say michael
jordan michael jordan pele
and maybe
for me it'd be michael jordan or pele
muhammad ali no
no no no no no no why not no no you know
what's funny though a lot of people
a lot of people do say bruce lee now
like when they think of like that's what
you hear you hear that you hear that so
much
he's a philosopher who his thing is is
like the legend of bruce lee we think
that he's this badass truth is he's 135
pound man who never
put it on the line competed a great
philosopher great businessman brought
the martial arts to america and created
a business plan that's great and was a
philosopher that's what i'm finding
dandy no but we're not
he's more like jordan peterson than he
is michael jordan what about michael
phelps who seems to be good for one
sport i don't think michael phelps would
be great in the other things
no it's just that sport so how do you
how do you put him in but again if we
were gonna go if it's very black and
white who was the most dominant athlete
at the highest level during their entire
career who scored the most points who
separated themselves from the pack it's
not even close it's wayne gretzky
no it's wayne gretzky not even close to
no one will ever touch his records alex
ovechkin is actually
very close to breaking his goal record
bring it up chin his goals but not not
assists in everything right no because
ovechkin's on track to be one of the
the best uh goal scorer in the united
states that'd be like lebron james
versus uh um
because then you gotta because when you
do that you gotta look up
how long ovechain played do you play
longer wayne gretzky it's harder
nowadays to score than it was i don't
care about that you do not i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm it's very black and white
you gotta look you gotta look at how
she's not black
when you guys says it that it's great
alex over will break his gold record
hockey league
894. once you believe on break roll feet
but the great one appears to know what
his mark is soon to fall
december 2021 but then what about
assists and all that but then but then
dude
just for goals overestimate is going to
be the greatest goal scorer so you ready
for this wayne gretzky ho and shares 61
records listed in the league's official
guide and record book 40 of the regular
scene 15 for stanley cup playoffs and
six for the all-star game but uh go
okay but wait hold on hold on yeah
do this how long how many years has uh
ovechkin played he got drafted in
2004 and i think his first season was
maybe
2006. i could be wrong because there was
a lockout 17th season how many scenes do
wayne gretzky play it's really easy to
figure out i love google all the time so
17.
probably the same probably saying
20 seasons and
ovechkin's closer to breaking this world
record now
but
one record
wayne grissom has 40. 60. but we were
just talking about aspects of goals you
were no no no no no no i'm talking all
records yeah
60. yeah yeah he's going to break one of
his 60. i thought i got confused i
thought you were just i said it's very
black and white okay but hold on it's a
numbers game here's the thing where's
the problem watch this so wayne gretzky
absolutely greatness now if you were to
take a decathlon you had like uh you
have a litmus test of speed
uh strength endurance all those things
that play a factor in all sports yeah
wayne gretzky's not coming close to a
lot of guys like
i don't know jordan uh uh any of these
amazing football players so so the the
question is how do we measure asteroids
tough yes stuff how do you measure it
because tom brady that's a [ __ ]
greatest i say it's the hardest i think
it's the hardest position in any sport
anywhere
i think so he's he's the go
slow
i mean not exactly blah blah but just
something about him right
so then you have to include gamesmanship
mindset
you know uh that x factor where you just
went you find a way to [ __ ] win that
doesn't matter because all the people
we're talking about has that many not to
that level they do though we're talking
about outliers they all all everyone
you've heard
all the great ones like yeah
yeah yeah yeah like but that that's
assumed those boxes are checked so you
gotta figure something else out so if
you make that if so so if you make that
the sort of the
if you take that out of it since they
all have it now you're left with
physicality
right but then you know because i don't
think wayne gretzky would run out 40 in
you know yeah but michael jordan can't
skate on ice so it doesn't matter yeah
no you can play that game i'm saying if
you if you if you had them bring up the
decathlon for a second because it's
actually a good uh it was it was
designed for this right so so look at
the decathlon so you got 100 meters
right
um
you got let take give me some give so
let's take let's say jordan uh who do
you want to do you want to do jordan
pele
uh just give me give me the phone i
don't know it's so strong
it's so stupid to do 100 meters long
jump shotput
high jump
400 meters on the first day 110 meter
hurdle
discus pole vault
javelin 1500 meter the second day i got
jordan on all of them
right or lebron on all of them no i
don't know i don't know how
well lebron's beating you in long jump
shot put 100 meters maybe hi john no no
no no no there's a lot of technique in
shot put well you if they focused on
that is what i'm saying well that's the
point but that's the point it's a tough
argument huh it's it's a never-ending
argument because the the best athletes
aren't running decathlon they're making
millions of dollars
no i'm saying you take all of them and
you have them from from kids yeah
that's stupid you might as well talk
about who'd win to fight bruce lee or
mighty mountain but it's worth thinking
about because you have a physical
component if they all have the mental
component
now you got to get now you got to jump
to the physical right that's where you
have but if you jump to the physical
then it's like where do you so you'd
have lebron there so because lebron
is a better kobe lebron well it's like
as far as physicality lebron's a more
physical presence than michael jordan
he's a better basketball player right is
he as fast yes all that and his verdict
he's a [ __ ] friend so you may have
he's six nine yeah so
he might he might be jordan in this i
don't know but again he's not better i
don't think he's better basketball
better basketball than jordan you know
it's weird
it's all it's so weird it's very weird
it's very difficult yeah i mean i don't
think it ever
so it's almost like you just got to say
great
of all time in their lane
and there's no you have argument for any
of them any of them so why would you and
uh matt matrion you you didn't even want
to talk about francis and ghana because
you don't know
or it's just that he hasn't it's tough
to talk about with especially with me
and matt because you're because
your standard's so high
we've been around real athletes real
athletes right there's a francis in
every single locker room in the nfl
that's on third string
there's a francis
and then if that guy would have decided
to fight like france is an outlier for
the ufc he's just a guy just maybe a
practice squad guy in the nfl with his
skills that's so [ __ ] nuts but again
then francis has his hands being stuff
like that well you would look at him and
say if he was a young guy you go you
know if he was 16 and he's that big and
strong he would probably be playing
football and learn the game if he grew
up in america he grew up in africa so
they don't really focus on it you know
so it's like he did this it's like a
kimuraju one was a goalie in soccer yeah
he played and then they were like why
don't you play basketball it's such a
weird yeah
no one's ever going to win the
conversation now you will lose it if you
say bruce lee
yeah that that that's what about that
full circle when he said bruce lee
that's why i started taking my mic
he's like no please come back and i know
this is like brandon marshall who's such
a friend i know he's so much better an
athlete and then and then when they both
said serena williams went well this is
even worse argument yeah we're talking
if female you have an argument yeah my
thing my thing with a guy like brandon
marshall or a guy like um lebron that
blows my mind is when i see dudes who
are six foot nine six foot five 230 260
pounds and they're that fast that agile
with that kind of balance and that kind
of endurance and they can jump that high
like
there are very few
small men
very few who can do what they do in fact
they can't that's what i think is
amazing but this is why i mean matt
didn't entert entertain your argument
because in the nfl
that's you see that in the locker room
all day long
everywhere if there's guys that aren't
even on the t didn't even make the team
well that's the hardest thing they're
running see those guys are hard knocks
they're like your hard luck is they're
freak and they don't make your team yeah
yes and no hard mics is hard knocks is
meant to create drama stuff like that
but there's there's
like the receiver for seattle he's a
[ __ ] freak who who uh uh tj metcalf
no no no that's that's very long ago but
um um it is metcalfe metcalf yeah he's a
freak from ole miss yeah he's a freak
he's a [ __ ] freak yeah he's got world
class speed he was running against
guys who only sprint and doing dk
metcalf yeah that's right dk metcalf
he's so he's
like 35. there's a picture of him before
the combine he's flexing like this and
you're like what in the [ __ ] it's so you
look at aaron dobbs
look at that
[ __ ] that's it that's a wide receiver
sir
who's the other guy's next to doesn't
matter but probably somebody just is
outback he used that too they both got
drafted goddamn but metcalf i mean
you're talking run jump yeah
it's a freak oh my god yeah bodied up
dude well that's just that's just a .01
percenter and then you bring up aaron
donald it's uh he's 290 pounds and he's
saying how about that
body fat
yeah i there's argument and you know me
no one writes hard for uh cooper cup
than me but there's alright look at that
that's a defensive tackle and he's 290
yeah yeah a defensive tackle he said
he's the best player in a long long time
but there's uh
there's argument he should you know i
love cooper cup but there's argument he
he should have been mvp
yeah yeah you could i i wish i did uh
offense and defense because he you know
cooper cup won the game scored the
touchdown but then aaron donald's really
the one that stopped them completely
from doing anything in that last drive
like he was such a disrupter i know
he's such a [ __ ] badass such a badass
he's such a monster
and unanimously the league has a vote of
best players in the league one through
50.
if
every single player at the highest level
voted for aaron donald that's how good
he is so he has the respect of everybody
amongst outliers yeah that's that's
that's the guy that's the guy no one's
like him he's the best we have
because they see him on film his first
step all that he's a mom i feel bad when
i see metcalf i see those guys i'm just
like she's [ __ ] did i come to realize
i i can't be a sports fan
i was i was getting panic attacks why i
can't like it's just stressful yeah like
to watch it like even when i was
watching the uh i was watching ufc
fights that's stressful i was just like
like i couldn't sit down really yeah
like my heart was beating fast you just
gotta watch it more maybe yeah it's
actually because i was watching you know
what it's very stressful when you when
you haven't seen fighting like that it's
actually puts you in a little bit of a
trauma like it when you i've sat with
guys who are macho dudes you know guys
who play sports when you watch when
you've never seen a ufc fight
especially in the beginning
like it's very it's a bit traumatic it's
very hard to watch yeah it really is i
think i just yeah like you said
consistently well i remind you i was
watching the artist
whitaker and i don't know why i didn't
like what were you watching at toby's
that's cool he was watching toby's but
yeah it was just like it just seemed so
like stressful to me like just because
because
yeah it's crazy if you're in person and
it's too heavy like if it's cyril don
and francis yeah you don't realize how
kind of barbaric it is if when you're
like kate's side yeah get in there like
what in the [ __ ] like oh
remember when you fought that and you
had that giant contusion and your
[ __ ] cheek was this big he fought
aloft in his cheek out of the ring the
blood couldn't drain he just filled up
so it was like it looked like it was
like puffed up it was like i was
carrying a [ __ ] miserable
awful dude yeah like i don't think i
could watch like the like the like the
derrick lewis knockout like when he got
knocked out or the elbow or canon yeah
uh getting uh look at that brunson
holy [ __ ] yeah that's bad enjoy that
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] yeah good times
[ __ ] uh
he's still doing it he just won
did you did you re-watch a b i did not
you did i watch on sunday what are your
thoughts izzy one yeah more accurate uh
he won at least three rounds clearly and
then you could even give him four yeah
whitaker
sure as [ __ ] won the fifth you could
give him the second if you want if
you're a whitaker fan so that's three to
two i don't see a third round for him
yeah because he definitely won that
fight oh people were arguing it oh yeah
big time but i think uh
you know those campaigns i really
shouldn't give my opinion because we
weren't watching we're [ __ ] around
i'm seven whiskey doubles deep and then
i look and i see whitaker like grappling
and so i'm like oh he's doing the bones
yeah i was like man i feel like whitaker
won that fight then when i watch him
like jesus christ yeah running close
yeah i was [ __ ] around yep we weren't
really watching it closely not that we
didn't watch any of them no oh why
because you you gave it to whitaker when
you were when you were doing the
campaign no i was like i was like i felt
like what everyone was fighting and i
was asking the guys but no one watched
it so i i really didn't know i saw him
land a good take down i don't know you
know you're trying to you just can't
canada is going to fight uh is that yeah
yeah
is he oh
yeah that's a yeah
yeah
yeah real real [ __ ] so canon here he'll
yeah he'll get in that quit tagging me
in his photos saying i look like him
really bad
i think we're just dark yeah you're both
all right well when he was bigger maybe
a little bit yeah yeah maybe that's on
the left on the left a little bit no
it's not so big
based off my lack of ufc knowledge so he
was fighting
and he was getting demolished and so he
just not demolished but he wasn't a
world beater he wasn't he was just a guy
at heavyweight he was just a guy a
heavyweight and so he dropped down to
light heavyweight light heavy and then
he was good and then when he got to 85
now he's world class got it that's crazy
he looks great yeah not everybody can do
could do that oh dude the amount of
discipline look at look from the first
to the third pick dude all right i i
give yeah it looks pretty i see what
they're saying on the left on the left
yes that's you on the left
that's you okay
take back the races
you're you're gonna look identical
you're not as in as good shape as he is
on the left he's oh i'm not shaped no i
don't know i know what i'm saying as you
can see the more re resemblance hey i'm
not saying how much i should see the
resemblance there i mean i feel in the
face it's just like in the face in the
face i see it not on the the far right
when he's like yeah
shreds bill threads yeah spaces in his
baby the most impressive thing about
canada look at his belly button
that's crazy he's got a tail piece on
him that's what i'm impressed with what
it did look at his belly button no it's
like smaller huge legs and a tail yeah
he had a huge belly button heavyweight
yeah i got a huge belly button right now
i need to get rid of that [ __ ] he even
looks good at light heavy hey i'm not
gonna lie uh for the super bowl yeah i
went on a hike
oh you missed super bowl i was just
watching the highlights no we're not gay
you're american
i was just too stressed i'm stressing
i'm listening i'm sorry are you fighting
the russians with ukraine
you
oh
are you do you leave on a flight to
ukraine tomorrow to fight the rush can i
see your passport dude yeah dude you you
went on a hike you missed the super bowl
i mean
on the hike you went by yourself yeah oh
wow there was no one up bro i went hike
with mark on i think thursday and i wore
the wrong shoes dude when i say my pinky
do i get seven band-aids on it i don't
know if you refer to as a corn or a
bunion a dude
hiking bro this toe is so tore up i was
limping all day yesterday look at me
just a nice hike it's a nice hike ain't
nothing wrong with that yeah that looks
nice and that's that's in the middle of
the super bowl so that's cool yeah it
was literally during the middle of the
super bowl interesting time to do it
no one was up there but like i said it's
just the sports [ __ ] [ __ ] stresses me
out
because i'm like okay i like the rams
but then white mike he's a cincinnati
bengals fan but he went to the game he
went to the game
people say it's like as far as like the
super bowl experience like best super
ball in forever oh really i guess the
half time show was lit too yeah i loved
it that's what i didn't see any halftime
show because
and there was eminem and drake and
kendrick and all that right yeah i'm not
drinking something
still relevant i still like watching
them i have no idea doing the same [ __ ]
sir the whole world does yeah no it's
course he's relevant yeah he's got he's
but how he just stays relevant yeah you
know he's 16 you know what it is it's
because he's cool with everybody
everyone [ __ ] it he like he crosses
over so many cultures awesome
i don't care what they say i still
listen to snoop yeah yeah i mean i'm
just so impressed with the fact that he
stays relevant yeah yeah he's just
staying cool he stays cool he's always
doing something to keep him in the
spotlight yeah there's always something
doing something keeping the spotlight
amazing but i was at that thing it was
feel you know a mix black and white yeah
tick-tock is all [ __ ] and then eminem
was doing you know the
lose yourself and they're singing and
dancing i went
i just like i don't have [ __ ] yeah i'm
talking
singing and dancing dude all of them
yeah around this tv like this
and then
i went outside and sat on the lawn by
myself i was like i just need a moment
of silence
i spent the half time how's it going was
the market did mark have a good time
yeah yeah he was listening all the food
oh of course he did that man can [ __ ]
eat like no way i've been that's muscle
no like it's insane but it's like a
different level of eating i've never oh
you love this he saw dc he's never met
dc before dc goes what's up master
blogger this is my boy marcus jesus
christ man you just roll with big dudes
there yeah you never know man he's
scaredy and then mark goes dc nice to
meet you as a marine county
is he introduced us as marine county
high school uh champion and dc goes you
bet you're actually right he goes
without physique you're
[ __ ] yeah you wrestled and i bet you're
a handful he goes
you know mark he's like champion
he kept going but he jokes around oh
kid
yeah that's [ __ ] great he's what's up
dc marine county
marine county he does not make himself
green county high school champion nice
to meet you
mark harley ladies and gentlemen it was
so hard i loved that kid and dc just
started laughing and he's like
marine county especially that coming
from mark that's hilarious that's great
yeah buddy with that fantastic haircut i
know
how fun was it seeing mitchell i want my
food brought to me and i get hungry when
i'm watching games fights or just
hanging out what do i do dude yeah dude
if you're binge watching your show man
list with grub hub you can get your
items delivered in 30 minutes or less
we're talking late night cravings
you got froyo we got it all man all
right whatever you're watching you don't
want to take a break you don't want to
cook
and this show is sponsored by grubhub
all right from extras to essentials
grubhub delivers all of your go-to
convenience items all day long through
their own convenience store their own
grubhub goods whether it's late night
snackaroo paper towels it's not just
soda
dude wow convenience items are delivered
right to your door just in the nick of
time you never have to leave your home
stay in your undies order your
convenience items from grub hub goods on
the app or online
how fun was you seeing mitrione because
your boys met your own too great on
campaigning too i hung with him and joe
schilling and i really liked joe
shillington yeah he and i drove down
together and uh it was good to catch up
with him but um i i love matt what did
you try on how did you guys go
uh we went to this place called the
shore bar that's why i was glad you went
with them because originally they were
like oh we might go to the whale one
don't go the way no like you two meet
heads i'm glad you told me that the
biker gang
that's their spot we don't want to mess
with you around yeah you also don't want
to it's you don't go down there but you
know matt and
matt they're both so cool that this they
you know i mean i i i can't excuse me
sir don't know
well excuse me yeah you don't want to
[ __ ] with joe i mean joe just not
yeah you know don't [ __ ] with him yeah
he's really nice but don't [ __ ] with him
you just want to put those guys in an
environment yeah cause they're not gonna
back down did luke rockled meet up with
you guys too no luke luke luke uh they
went off they went they wanted to keep
matt will keep the party going i mean
i'm gonna be more opposite because he
goes what are you doing i go what do you
mean yeah cause what are you doing now
you'll
go home and try and go to bed and he
goes you don't go out and go dude
working that party is the closest thing
i've been
to a party in 10 years
matt and kayla's wife they will keep the
party going because they were like hey
what's next i was like well i gotta go
to bed they were like seriously that day
they're on the phone
on venice beach he was like yeah because
he texted me hey man i can't drive i
mean uber we've been doing shrooms like
did you get
realize it's a marathon not a sprint my
man we got four hours of content he goes
i'm a professional i'll be sober what
time you get to yeah he came here and
sure enough he's at venice beach all day
he's awesome
matt is uh just a [ __ ] was that was
it like uh it's like a bar you guys went
to a short club yeah restaurant every
time i go to indiana he i hang with him
and his crew of course and he's just uh
he's just always a good time yeah he's
the best he's just uh i this there's a
but there's an interesting thing about
him which is like he's got a sense of
humor about himself which i always love
but he also has a wonderful
insecurity to himself like that like he
doesn't he's not like is he's the
biggest strongest guy in the world but
he doesn't
he i don't know he just doesn't he's a
big exude that he's a big kid he's a big
kid he's a big wild boy love him wild
boy he's great on companion yeah chris
loved him yep fantastic
and it's not easy to jump into that crew
and
gel fast you know like can't we can't
just toss i told him that i said dude
you yeah yeah very hard it's hard to fit
in that's not an easy crew i mean the
mount would you know known each other we
speak a language yeah chris and i had
the things
that sympathy there you know you don't
want matt you know but he was good at
letting everybody do their thing and not
killing the [ __ ] he's great yeah team
player he just knows how to he's great
in and out
yeah he's great it's such a good time
he's looking bigger than ever and i mean
muscly i said i said matt right if you
saw the toms
what are we doing he goes i'm hiding
underneath the bleachers he's a big kid
he what i'm gonna
neither one of us is passing and you
sign a test right now because absolutely
not
he's thick
dick
he doesn't post a lot there's a
christmas that's him right there bottom
yeah that's he did the trailer fight
oh okay
he's still i think he's gonna find a lot
of me getting ready
i think there's some some trailer off
from some another boxing thing it's just
good money for him and who's the other
guy schilling joe schillings
he's the most decorated he's a most
decorated american kickboxer
ever
and he big boy too
uh slender
962 yeah like in shape though yeah yeah
and you almost like i love showing
because he's no i tell him not to go
showing smokes shilling he smokes
cigarettes he's a smoker
i mean he's embarrassed like before the
fight has smoked sick it's a [ __ ] man
yeah a man smoking he'll smoke before he
kicks your ass and after he kicks your
ass he smokes
like that's something
that's steve mcqueen's [ __ ] like that's
old school old school
paul newman steve mcqueen like like a
man's man
he's a man's man yeah he really is fight
fights yeah he's tough as they come yeah
just tough as they come just yeah you
don't want to talk [ __ ] to him in a
karaoke not a good idea no not a guy
learned the hard way yeah
yeah oh he knocked him dude on the
karaoke bar well the guy [ __ ] came at
him did this to him you know flinched at
him oh that's oh that's that dude yeah
that would be joe yeah
joe was minding his own business and i'm
not gonna and the guy was like
talking about the guy was like he's
antagonizing him yeah joe goes what you
don't see in the video that's the guy
that knocked out oh of course that guy
he was everybody in the bar [ __ ] with
that no but the the complete thing
everybody misses is that guy there's a
busboy from nigeria black kid yup and
the kids start to call him the n word
yep oh joe and saw it across the table
he's like what the [ __ ] and the kid was
like like he said he wasn't just boy
yeah yeah but he was like what he was
like bullying him he kept calling the
n-word and then so joe sat down and
someone told him like hey man i wouldn't
[ __ ] with that guy and the guy's like
[ __ ] that guy he was across the other
table and kept like you ain't gonna do
[ __ ] and joe's like okay dude and then
joe is ignoring it and then gets up and
the guy flinches at him like he's gonna
hit him that's when you know joe
shouldn't popped off on him oh joe's
gonna be fine i won't tell he's going
through the process now but he's gonna
be fine
yeah
i won't see that video great please play
stupid games win stupid prizes play
stupid games yeah that's right
i mean it's a great saying
people get that [ __ ] don't be [ __ ]
around chin what do you got dude
all right
a couple guys tried to [ __ ] with amir
khan like that i think tony told me that
they tried to [ __ ] with amir khan and
his brother and these two guys kind of
skin heady guys big kind of white dudes
in england and started calling them
pakis or something and
and amir was like oh i'm going to knock
you out now and so is my brother and
they knocked them the [ __ ] out right
there on the street
america i can see people [ __ ] with
amir khan because he's this big but joe
schilling is not small no he probably
had a cigarette his mouth
it's like out of all the guys out of all
the guys don't get that guy with a
thousand yard stare no that's like
buying a snake get bit and snakes doing
snake [ __ ] right joe schilling doing so
joe heard that dude calling nick doing
something joe schilling doing joe
schilling [ __ ] yeah he saw him bullying
that that kid he's a young busboy and
kept calling the n-word he was a black
guy he was just [ __ ] and joe was like
i do not get down this bullying man and
then would still ignore it jose i'm not
gonna do anything and the guy kept
talking [ __ ] well no he was apparently
he was he was singing rap songs at joe
like like but across the room staring at
him you know but still is you're
taunting a [ __ ] yeah another person
and then no he got mad he got dealt with
it
he had dealt with
do you watch video again yeah
i guess joe wants us to bring this up so
go to the short one
right here 49
it look this looks like a movie set this
looks like a movie set
yeah it looked a little weird when we
first saw it didn't make any sense
especially because it's being walked by
the guy bumped into him and then he
talked [ __ ] to him and then flinches at
him
oh
man he just he made that move
i mean well there you go
bro he's straight up
i'm here for the show
there can be yeah
eddie's a good dude but it's just like
he has a special set of skills man
that's not the guy you want to talk [ __ ]
to out of i would say anybody on the
fight right it's also not the guy you
want to do this too you don't want to
come at him like yeah because he's going
to react well that guy showed that to
the cops yeah it was like look at this
this guy hit me and they go well you
flinched at him like you that's a move
of aggression yeah and he retaliated
like
in court you can get eaten alive with
this man the guy was like
okay like walk down the police station
cops like yeah you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
dummy any like guy guy that sees that's
like yeah that's what you get yeah and
there are a lot of people i believe in
the bar who probably are going to talk
about how aggressive he was being with
everybody they didn't need that that
guy's [ __ ] yeah i won't get into it
but i was talking to sheldon about that
gets [ __ ] yeah i mean here he got
knocked down he's you know and he's
getting annihilated on social media so
he got what he got yeah yeah what else
you got jen right
so kanye west went on a uh posting
rampage on instagram where he's posting
a lot of different memes uh with pete
davidson and then he was talking
yeah he
created a feud with billy eilish because
i guess at a concert recently there was
a fan who needed their inhaler she
stopped the concert made sure the fan
was okay and she said something along
the lines of i make sure that people are
okay at my concerts we take care of
ourselves she's like throwing shade at
travis yeah she didn't uh say him
outright but you can tell that it's a
shot at travis
and then you know that's his boy then
connie goes cool until you apologize i'm
not playing coachella with you like i'm
the headliner i'm not playing coachella
with you unless you apologize to my
friend which i who said that kanye said
that said that too
because she's like through shade at
travis yeah he's obviously dealing with
a lot of [ __ ] right now yeah and
connie's like no that ain't cool which i
respect he's like down my head i guess
she didn't say anything about him right
she did though she she it was like this
it was a subliminal shot she was
definitely we take care of our own you
know what that's like me going to see uh
you know being a bar and a guy's
flinching at me go i don't knock guys
out i'm not that type of dude clearly
it's a reference to joe schilling okay i
don't know what she said i'm sorry i
don't know what she's no she yeah this
is definitely an illusion this is a
tragedy
and kanye proceeded to write a instagram
post about it saying that he doesn't
want to perform in coachella unless
billy issues an apology because travis
will be at coachella even though he may
or may not be performing which i like
which i like when people get down with
their guys because everyone's going back
to cape cod everyone's throwing travis
under the [ __ ] bus yeah
kanye that's his guy so i like when
people defend their guides the only
issue with this is that kanye doesn't
seem to be well when he's doing this
he's definitely
having an episode or having a moment and
so he then proceeds to but i don't see
why this is but
so kanye says this defends a friend now
it's like no he's not well he's off some
medication or he's defending his [ __ ]
friend i think that's true but it's also
all the posts that followed because
like kanye said i'm with him on this he
goes all right so i post 15 posts
everyone says i'm crazy but the news you
watch post [ __ ] non-stop and you guys
are fine with that yeah crazy because i
go off it doesn't mean that you go off
like cute cut is here too bad i want to
be on your album you [ __ ] dinosaur ha
ha everyone knows i've been the best
thing about your albums since i met you
i'ma pray for you brother
like all right thank you and that one's
a little like little psy thing that's
weird because um he said that because
kid cudi and p davidson are friends and
then kid cudi is also friends with billy
eilish he's not going to be on the donda
2 record but kid cudi came out saying i
wasn't going to be on it anyways kanye
told me weeks ago that he was going to
cut me from his album we were fine about
it but now he's using this as leverage
for everything that's happening with him
and billy eilish and pete davidson it's
weird i mean today he's going to i guess
he went bad on pete davidson and you
know i don't know i think what all this
is is kanye's just hurt man this is very
hurt yeah you know like kim kim's moved
on she would be here
but he's also got some issues i think
when he's off his medication he tends to
be a little bit and i think that for me
if i know he will react differently to
those type of situations i'm not
responding to kanye when he does that i
think you make a mistake about
responding i think you have to
understand he might be having her i
don't think anyone's really the only
ones responding with kid cuddy everyone
else no one's responding yeah no one's
playing the game yeah
but his post you know he's trending over
the super ball on super well sunday
that's how powerful gun is yeah he was
the number one trending thing in the
world off these posts instead of the
super bowl
it's crazy
did you see his mask when they showed
him oh yeah there's like little holes
over it oh he looks hilarious
he's with uh what's it called uh av yeah
antonia brown yeah yeah he's wearing a
whole mask around his whole face yeah
and then you just see like little holes
so he can kind of see through it like
this is so interesting
that would be miserable to watch a game
right there i think
damn his daughter looks identical he's
amazing though by the way he can cover
his whole body and all we do is talk
about him right you know it's him
i'm gonna dress that way
no you're not brian no because i want
people to think um so it just has those
like little holes in it but he took it
off right here it looks like antonio
brown's sitting next to him or something
looks like he's losing weight san
antonio brown yeah
he's he's the head of uh donda athletics
oh wow he's trying to get kanye to buy
the broncos
all right what else you guys got
so um this was making a few headlines
because during the triple half time
performance eminem took a knee and
people were saying that it's an allusion
to colin kaepernick taking a knee and
there are different speculations about
whether the nfl had
told him not to nfl came out was like
we have no issue with this yeah exactly
a lot of people were running with this
idea that it was from the nfl yeah
people were just [ __ ] trying to start
they're looking for
yeah it's just him yeah [ __ ] taking a
need during the thing they said in in
when he's doing rehearsals
yeah he was doing the same thing yeah
reversal so they know that so it's like
and also like immediately it goes to a
tupac song
so it could be i mean
[ __ ] everybody but i think because nfl
thing is a colin kaepernick thing yeah i
don't think it is yeah at all
these people are stupid yeah i also get
a little gosh i [ __ ] hate the
internet
anderson pack yeah for them it's
interesting to talk about right it's a
narrative i guess
okay well so this one's for you brian i
don't know too much about this but
apparently the daughter and grandson of
uh that
of john gotti is currently suing
somebody named jean barello cause he has
been harassing their family for a while
and
apparently the last straw for the family
and the reason why they decided to sue
him was because he started doing deep
fakes with their face on pornography and
sending it out on the internet yeah
so it's amazing well calm down dude
fakes are really
i know a journalist aleister bostwick
who did this
he put he deep faked his own face on a
gay porn
uh just to he wrote a whole article
about it about how you're able to do
this now and he did it to himself on gay
porn hilarious as he's getting railed
and he's like look at what you can do to
somebody but what's crazier is this he
was talking about this he said with deep
fake technology
somebody can go online as the head of
the federal reserve
as you know whoever's that janet yellen
whoever the [ __ ] is the chairman and say
we're raising interest rates by one
percent two percent
now you're going to find out that's fake
but the marketplace is going to react
immediately
and then whoever shorts that stock or
goes along on that stock
is going to make a [ __ ] load of money
and so that's the biggest thing about it
but i think what's going to happen is
they're going to come out they're going
to go wait a minute this might be as
soon as it happens you're going to have
verification like there should be like a
stamp on it where you know it's the real
one and not the fake yeah that's pretty
easy to handle but yeah it could be a
problem yeah yeah
for the new cycles can be weird you know
but there's going to be a verification
thing like twitter like i'm sure there's
fake accounts of big celebrities unless
has that blue check nobody takes it
seriously yeah the same thing with this
deep fakes right
but they can do your voice and
everything too it's crazy it's only
going to get crazier have you guys
played the game wordle before no say it
again wordle
i've seen people post about this game i
don't know exactly what it is but it's a
word game online and this woman plays
very often with her daughter and one day
the 80 year old woman didn't send her
results to her daughter which she does
daily
and the daughter knew something was
wrong so she called the police and they
found out that her mother was actually
kidnapped jesus holy [ __ ] like she was
so consistent with sending her wordle
results to her daughter because they
that's how they would bond throughout
the day yeah
they found out something was wrong then
and there and her mother
uh this article did not say but somebody
had broken into her house and kidnapped
her
and because she didn't text her daughter
her results that day the police were
able to find her jesus christ
wow
all right but yeah she's fine
everything's good sounds good what are
you guys doing for valentine's day
today's valentine's day huh yeah yeah
it's fake holiday fake scam
but you know you got to buy flowers oh
yeah i did that
chin forgot
well now it's on here
i bought it literally today at on a shop
show
guy didn't i ran out this morning and
did my [ __ ] you did
good i mean at least we did it that's
what matters right it's all it counts
valentine's day it's in fact it's not
for us
i don't like it either yeah i think
hallmark made it mad it's bs but flowers
i guess you kind of have to do it though
that do something like that
be cool if you had a girl who didn't
give a flying [ __ ] yeah my girl doesn't
care but i just feel like you got to do
something i don't know because i can't
because my mom
she doesn't care and then when her
friends are posting [ __ ] online except
you did nothing it's gonna cause
problems for you exactly yeah they like
to say that they're significant of the
game
picture of the [ __ ] flowers what else
we got
uh this is heather mcdonald do you guys
remember that one
okay so [ __ ] crazy i'll be honest
when i first heard about this story i
don't know why i have this really
skeptical mind i'm like oh are they you
know did you make it up no that's my
initial response but then i want to get
proof so i saw this video and it's like
she really passed oh she really [ __ ]
passed out yeah
skull right yeah yeah and then i say
this and then this happens okay so we're
gonna play i'm happy trigger warning
tibia i don't mean to brag i don't care
but i want you to know
double vaxxed
booster
flu shot
and i'm gonna be honest
i have the shingle shot too
and i still get my period what yes
traveled
went to mexico twice
did shows meet and greets
never got coveted clearly watch yourself
right now jesus loves me the most
seriously right now right when she says
that jesus goes no no
yeah right here
the way that she hits the back of her
head they thought it was a joke
[Music]
oh no
what was that do we know is that a is
that so she type
so they're she's not saying
i mean if anything [ __ ] that was like
crazy yeah she's talking about getting
all these vaccines she got so i got
booster three weeks to the day of the
fall if there's anything you've seen
time wise so she talked to true about
three weeks yeah so you talked to drew
about it and he's like that's around the
timeline if you're gonna have a negative
effect
i mean i don't put words in his mouth
but that's what i kind of that's when
really that's what you gather because
that came on yeah that came on suddenly
like she had a cat she could tell she
was like oh oh something's happening and
then the way she felt oh yeah yeah and
that's how she fractured her yeah yeah
that's not like that hard to fracture a
skull i guess she's an older lady but
that that floor is yeah it's like
hardwood [ __ ] or that floor
is pretty [ __ ] i think comedy floors
are soft fellas you know what i'm saying
no that's what i'm saying like
even though they're all hard wise no
that's what i'm saying though not soft
that's carpet but the whole point is
still not like soft yeah you fall on
this when you're [ __ ] up the whole
point is not it's not her age it's like
it's a hard floor she got she hit it
hard yeah
i mean i don't think any i don't think
chappelle's skull is going to fracture
if he hits the ground like that oh you
can't fracture your skull hold on let's
look at the fall again what do you mean
you don't think so
that on that floor
apparently
she said jesus loves me watch look watch
oh jesus boom he hit her head on the mic
dude she went down so weird it looks
like she hit her head on the mic down so
mike's weird
no bro i think she fell on the damn
floor fell on her the back of her head
yeah
that way she's hitting him
my friend's mom died that way she felt
like a lot of people died that way yeah
people in street fights that way yeah
100 when you hit the back of your head
very dangerous i thought if she was
gonna if there was a uh someone that
just wants attention it would be like oh
yeah
i'll tell you what's even weirder i
don't know if you guys have it but the
autopsy came out on yeah
on uh on bob's side
bob sage yeah yeah dude they said his br
his head was fractured
they said it would have took a baseball
bat to get it done
like he wouldn't just fall out of bed
like it was either a car crash or a
baseball bat to get it done yeah he said
that's what you see when somebody falls
20 stories or something from really so
here it is so autopsy includes uh scalp
abrasions
hemorrhaged blood forms between the
skull and scalp
discoloration the upper and lower
eyelids do skull fracture subdural
hematoma buildup of blood and surface of
the brain
um hemorrhage
it's so it's every year more than 61 000
americans die from traumatic brain
injury and many of these are due to
falls
and if you keep going yeah there's more
there's a ton more well he was also on
blood thinners so
okay
okay but it's dude it's [ __ ] they
said it would either be a baseball bat
or fall from 30 stories to do this
impact christ
i think the bigger question is the
mechanism of uh there being just a minor
head trauma which is just feels less
like this doesn't smell like a benign
head drama here looks like someone who
had a major role down the stairs car
accident bicycle accident a motorcycle
accident maybe he fell when he went to
get to go to the bathroom and hit his
head
and then got into bed but then he had
like orbital injuries as well yeah but i
wonder if he fell backwards like but he
had a fall like that he got out to go to
the bathroom
fell in his head and then just got back
into bed and then tied i don't know but
why was his face be fractured if you
fell backwards well if you fall
backwards you can still crack your head
to here you know you could that'd be
tough bubba that'd be really tough no
it's not it's not that'd be really tough
to fracture the front when you fell on
the back
you would have to fall so
so the doctors said we've only seen
trauma like this from baseball bat
beatings to the brain or somebody who
fell 30 stories but bob's about 6'3 i
think if you fell from that distance and
you hit like say that the bathroom floor
if it was marble that would happen and
maybe it got so here's what a doctor
said you might be right b here's what
the doctor said things that's tougher to
track are the fractures to have a
fracture you have to have enough blunt
force on a bone directly on a bone in
order to fracture it says doctor it's
very hard to fracture your orbit without
traumatizing your orbit
so if you hit the back of your head the
chances of your orbit breaking is damn
near impossible
what the [ __ ] it's like he was he was
injured he was killed or something right
but they'd had that on video but it's so
weird i mean would they have it on video
i mean
hotels ritz carlton
they're they're they're definitely gonna
have to probably do an
investigation but there was no sign of a
struggle there's no there's no like foul
play or whatever they say no in the
talks college report there's nothing
right maybe there's some crazy
security guy who likes to kill people in
their sleep i don't feel like a dexter
type but i mean
it's all so if i was his family i'd be
going nuts yeah anyone
excuse me yeah yeah this doctor just
said
that his [ __ ] eye the orbitals of his
eyes and the major head trauma could he
have fallen face first
like tripped over something but then his
they would have said the face they would
have seen i would imagine that they
faced something blood or something on
the ground too i don't know even though
what the first reports are like nothing
looked like foul play if he hit his head
really bad you'd see some something
right and also why would he why would he
go to sleep yeah
i'll just go like that
first it's not just go to sleep that's
what i'm saying what have you got to go
to the bathroom fell face first got you
know now you're concussing and you're
disoriented you climb into bed you get a
bed and die oh i mean that's possible
that's the only thing i can think of but
he didn't fall facebook
they said he was laying there i don't
yeah i don't know he didn't
i don't know
if i was his family i would be going
yeah nuts
nuts wow
it's it's creepy you just hate that man
for his family because this is weird
like up in the air type of like vibe now
you want closure yeah you want closure
man and to like i'm not creating a
conspiracy here but
sam tripley will be oh sam's like
interesting i'm like here we go
the beat your ass yeah group chat they
sent me that one oh something's going on
here yeah so everyone's like something's
going on it's like you can't
who knows how do you how do you justify
that
obama if you're a family there's no way
you're just taking this on the chin like
okay that makes sense i'm like no no no
we got to reopen this the doctor says
this is consistent with things i've seen
when people get hit with a baseball bat
here like or a car or falling from
falling for 20 stories clearly didn't
all right well what's the latter good
chance you would get hit with a baseball
bat he didn't fall from the 30 stories
so your autopsy is not helping me here
we got to figure this out yeah
i'd look more into it what else you got
jen um let's see look into it
oh she's clear this one's making yeah
this one's making a lot of news this 15
year old i think she's 15 year old
figure skater she got popped in december
but she's still allowed to compete
in this ceremony because they have to do
an investigation oh so the olympics
decided yet but they're saying that uh
it's a dopey thing yeah hey can i can i
say this i want to be very clear yeah
i don't know what it is i have no idea i
don't know what it is usually i care
about the olympics i like the summer
olympics
when i tell you i don't give anything
i i knew i knew you're gonna say about
the winter olympics this year for
whatever reason you jump into it yeah
great athlete yep some inspirational
story sure when i say i haven't watched
a [ __ ] blink of it yeah
i bet the ratings and maybe my worlds
don't know is it just because you don't
know any of the athletes you haven't
followed them or what is it no i'm stay
current with it i was i decided for sean
wait sean white to compete
he finished fourth yeah i just don't
give a [ __ ]
i don't know what it is i don't care i
do not care in the least bit don't have
it at the house i've watched for the
first time a lot of it and you've been
watching it brian yeah that downhill
skiing the difference between like first
and forth is like pointing to two
seconds yeah
like weird i i it's a hustle and i
appreciate their effort i like when they
fly on the ski when they do that thing
where they yeah that's what bob sledge
[ __ ] annoys me i i just didn't imagine
going yeah the curl is it curling that
annoys me that [ __ ] is [ __ ] good i
don't know i don't give a [ __ ] yeah i
don't understand the curling i like
figure i would i would assume the rate
ratings are down though i don't watch it
i don't know who else wants i don't know
i don't know anybody that's up to date
on well i've heard one person say hey
man did you see well you know what the
chinese aren't allowing a lot of people
in the stadium so there isn't that
there's nothing yeah he's that badass
snowboarder and she's she's from i think
torrance california this badass
snowboarder she's asian oh yeah she's
asian
because her family can't come because
they're in china they can't come so
should put on uh her cell phone on her
chest and it's goes live on ig and lets
her family
see her race oh that's cool that's
pretty dope she looks at the camera here
we go put it on [ __ ] crushes
she's such a beast and she's
super pretty let me see that girl's
gonna make who's all the [ __ ] man i'm
guessing you're talking about she's a
korean girl for the time of her from
from toronto maybe someone else no
that's right okay that's her she won the
gold she's a freak uh yeah she's a ki
yeah she's making all the time to make
all
she's 17 she's on the front cover of
[ __ ] times like yep
nike athletes
she's like the next big superstar to
blow the [ __ ] up damn yeah superstar i
think i do think her parents are both
korean but i don't know for a fact but i
think they might be but she's born in
torrance yeah i'm surprised not a surfer
and she's like my dad took me
snowboarding the only thing i was good
at so i kept doing it wow that's amazing
yeah no she's 21.
she's 21. yeah you don't say she's 21
from oh dude she won gold when she was
17. she's only five she's only five
three so she's she's from long beach
long beach just said long beach okay
just making sure we're probably ripping
she's 21 now but she won the first gold
when she was 17. yeah freak
pretty dope um
all right um we just cared more guys
yeah
we didn't get into enough mma stuff on
uh our show but then there's something i
want to show you guys real quick
oh this one here
so
you guys watch the obviously a fight
company roxanne mata fairy some judge
gave her
the win right when then that girl casey
o'neil absolutely won the entire fight
so then this guy aaron braun said it was
saying like it doesn't take a rocket
science to actually judge it yeah the
guy is actually a rocket scientist but
that means fighting though that's very
funny complete opposite
i know but dude 25 years of motion that
time supported support of nasa that's
hilarious the job has taken roles into
the space shuttle international space
station space launch system programs
his job title includes safety engineer
operations manager robotics specialist
he's a [ __ ] brilliant man yeah
doesn't mean he knows fighting correct
yeah but i mean so he actually judged
another fight wrong too i don't know i
don't remember which one was but he this
is the second fight that he judged
completely how did he find these judges
i don't even know uh you're you're
picked by the commission or you're you
you're not you're not picked you apply
they don't just pick oh you have to
apply to do it yeah that's correct they
show them randomly yeah you gotta apply
you can't like train
there was a school for it i don't listen
this guy's a rocket scientist
and he was like i'll try it out yeah
yeah i mean just because he's smart i'm
bored with rocky just because he's smart
he's probably thinking about [ __ ]
rockets and getting us to mars you don't
give a [ __ ]
you know about leg kicks nothing yeah
that's so funny
you don't be a rocket scientist well
well actually in fairness
that's hilarious yeah
all right that's pretty much it all
right kids
well i'll see you this thursday uh san
diego american comedy company uh night
it was just yeah just one night and then
i got las vegas nobody with sam triple a
diversion amusements february 19th is
that this week come get some yeah yeah
this saturday diversion amusements two
shows me and sam are going to debate he
thinks that cove is a false flag
operation i'm gonna be telling him he's
full of [ __ ] i'll bring my evidence
he'll bring his and then we'll do stand
up after that come see us appleton
wisconsin march third the fifth that's
why we can't do that [ __ ] fight
companion in phoenix arizona oh
you're gone and chris is gone yeah i
mean i'll have to do a fight
without you guys phoenix arizona stand
up live march 11th i'll have to rally
the troops and figure that one out
uh where my next shaban friends be our
fifth sold out show hollywood improv
shopping friends we got some monsters
that's february 23
23rd one show one night only 8 p.m at
the hollywood improv in la and then back
on the road thick boy tour strikes up
again sacramento california punch line
february 24-26
and then
march we got nashville tennessee zany's
one of my favorite clubs march 10th
through the 12th in chicago's march
24-26
boom and then uh kansas city february
25th and 26th at the comedy club of
kansas city march 10th through the 12th
uh blue room comedy club in springfield
missouri and then april 8th and uh april
9th salt lake city wise guys comedy club
all right kids that's it we love you see
ya